michel petrucciani le pianiste de jazz
décédé la semaine dernière à new york à
l'âge de 36 ans a été inhumé au
cimetière du père lachaise à paris
ce matin vous le voyez en l'église saint
roch de nombreuses personnalités des
politiques et des musiciens ont rendu un
dernier hommage à ce géant du jazz
je vous propose d'écouter quelques
réactions de ses amis et de ses
admirateurs
la première cassette que j'ai acheté
j'ai 30 ans je lâche que je crois que
j'avais 12 ans donc ça faisait quatre ou
cinq ans j'étais professionnel reconnu
fois un sacré monsieur qui est parti il
étions d'accord sur le fait que le jazz
devait rester redevenir si possible
d'une musique populaire
la vie et la mort en particulier
évidemment des pros n'a pas tendance à
s'en féliciter
mais quand on croit en la poterie on
voit la poterie aussi et on croit
finalement une sorte et sp2
decker noté
et pour les couche-tard france 3 rend
hommage aux environs de 1h30 à michel
petrucciani en diffusant le récital
enregistré au festival de jazz d'antibes
en 97